[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi j'aime le musical ses jongleurs ses
danseuses légères
et public qui rigole quand il voit les
petits chiens blancs portant faux col
moi j'aime tous les samedis quand Paris
allume ses
lumières prendre vers
8h30 un billet pour être assis au trè
rang pas trop loin mais déjà V rideau
rouge qui bouge qui bouge bouge
l'orchestre attaque un ancien du temps
de Maillo bravo c'est drôle c'est très
drôle ça c'est du bon souvenir du muguet
qui ne meurt pas
cousine
comme elle
poussit
soupir les jeunes filles d'entend du
monde ou de l'usine qui sont devenus à
présent de vieill grand-mamans ce fut
vraiment Félix MAOL bourreau des cœurs
de leur
music mais depuis
1900 si les jonglurs n'ont pas changé
sil a toujours ma chevalier
geor
brass et Charles
TR il y a aussi dieu merci Paul Nar du
Tron nin
fer moi j'aime le
Music c'est le refuge des chanteurs
poètes ceux qui se monent pas du col et
qui reste pour ça le grand grand
gentille Vette pour moi j'aime Juliette
Greg m les frères JAC j'aime à tous les
échos Charles navour
gilbertchos che les boulevards de Paris
mon temps qui sourit les
chante chante j'adore aussi ce grand
garçon de la chanson Les Compagnons ding
ding
ça c'est du
musical on dira tout ce qu'on peut en en
dire mais ça restera toujours
[Musique]
l'écoleon apprend à mieux voir entendre
applaudir à sé mouvoir en se fondant de
larme ou de rire voilà
pourquoi j'aimerais toujours le musicant
j'aimerais toujours toujours toujours
toujours
toujours le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
musical